we're here the sanctuary we have our own
motto that we believe in and it's saving
one animal may not change the world
but surely for that one animal of the
world will change forever and we fully
believe that because we see it every day
my name is Pat Craig I'm the executive
director and founder of the Wild Animal
Sanctuary located in keansburg Colorado
the sanctuary was started 36 years ago I
visited a zoo one time so I was really
surprised to see all these lions and
tigers in the back kept in tiny little
cages and I found out they were surplus
and that they actually euthanized those
animals so I opened the first sanctuary
in the country for large carnivores oh
so in the beginning I started on the
family farm right outside of Boulder
Colorado at the time you know I dropped
out of school and started working
full-time to support the animals and
build more space and go get more animals
we started to get phone calls from law
enforcement agencies who are finding
apartments and in basements about 85% of
all the animals here were legal
confiscations from people who either
abused them or had them illegally and
the rest either come from zoos circuses
or other places like that that have them
we have over 420 rescued carnivores
living here and everything from wolves
tigers bears lions leopards mountain
lions you name it I mean there's a lot
of mouths to feed
we feed over 38,000 pounds of food a
week these animals are absolutely like
my kids just because this is my life
turned into a seven day a week 365 day a
year job that I've been doing for 36
years and you know there is no time to
go anywhere for vacations or anything
else it's all for the animals wasn't
something I expected to do and it would
had no idea how monumental I was going
to get but it's been worth it every bit
of the time so I wouldn't never wouldn't
have changed at all
you